why is everyone staring at us I don't
know it's like I feel like we're dressed
so normal Kylie Jenner and Haley Bieber
getting into the spooky season it was so
scary scary and Brilliant the besties
are twinning in Wicked Witch of the West
looks Kylie documenting their wacky
adventure on Tick Tock as they step out
in head to toe body pain why is everyone
staring at us I don't know it's like I
feel like we're dressed so Marvel yeah
so it makes no sense oh no my arm's
poking out over on the gram Haley shared
the beginning of their night at home you
know a green Kylie lounging in a tub
cuddling a skeleton in the comments
famous faces were just as confused as we
were Khloe Kardashian asked WTF is
happening Kris Jenner was equally
curious she wrote OMG what's happening
over there yay
out but leave it to Ashley Graham to put
on her detective hat and ask the million
dollar question did you lose the game a
reference to Haley's web series welcome
to who's in my bathroom yeah you know
the show Haley plays games with
celebrity guests and the loser always
gets a penalty like when she played
never have I ever with Kylie sis Kendall
okay
blend so bad
my sister pulled a knife on me
what is this turns out Ashley was spot
on the show's production company
confirmed Kylie's upcoming appearance
but gotta say we're not exactly
surprised because Kylie's famous fam
always goes all out for the holiday
s just have fun with it my birthday's
near Halloween so I'd always have my
birthday slash Halloween party together
in our family there's so many birthdays
right around Halloween
Kim Caitlyn Kendall my mom and then
Corey and dream are on the same day so
we have a lot of reasons to dress up
have fun celebrate and celebrate is
exactly what Kylie does she's channeled
many icons like Barbie and The Little
Mermaid and remember when Haley dressed
as the princess of pop I thought it was
really brilliant really fun but back to
Haley and Kylie's random night out we
don't know the exact terms of the game
they played but any night that ends with
pizza seems like a win for all
my friends took me to uh go get pizza
casual so it makes no sense
[Music]
[Music]